[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in rheine torten
wählt heute möchte ich euch ein rezept
vorstellen und zwar ist es eine spielart
lachs rolle
ihr könnt dieses gericht ganz gut als
vorspeise servieren oder eben zu seiner
kalten platte alles buffet und ihr
braucht auch nur ganz wenige zutaten
dafür die rolle ist sehr schnell gemacht
und lässt sich auch sehr gut vorbereiten
was ihr an zutaten benötigt das zeige
ich euch jetzt für den teig braucht ihr
vier eier
ich habe mich schon mal getrennt in
eiweiß und eigelb ihr braucht 225 gramm
spinat da ist tiefgefroren ihr könnt
aber auch frischen spinat nehmen
ihr braucht pfeffer muskatnuss und
salzen und für die füllung braucht er
etwas räucherlachs und 200 gramm spricht
es so erst gebt ihr jetzt das eiweiß in
eine schüssel
da kommt jetzt eine gute prise salz
betreiben das wird jetzt einmal schön
steif geschlagen so kurz zur seite
wie bereits erwähnt könnt ihr auch
frischen spinat verwenden den solltet
ihr dann vorher kurz blanchieren in
heißem wasser
ich benutze aber ganz gern tiefgekühlten
spinat weil dati vitamine eben noch
erhalten sind da nämlich direkt nach der
ernte eingefahren und bei frischem
spinat weiß man eigentlich sind nie so
richtig ob der jetzt schon länger im
laden stand oder eben frisch angeliefert
wurde
von daher nehme ich das gern die
tiefgekühlten aber wenn ich den anderen
neben wort ist natürlich auch okay dann
müsst ihr euch um
blattspinat und die eigelbe kümmern die
werden jetzt miteinander verrührt und
ich mache es einfach weil es schneller
und einfacher geht im thermomix da kommt
jetzt einfach da blattspinat rein die
verkehre dann kommt da noch etwas frei
und der etwas muskatnuss die muss
natürlich nicht sein aber ich bin das
passt mir ganz gut denn es steht sogar
noch ein bisschen pfeffer rein also
schilling jetzt setzt sich das hier auch
meine maschine und lasst es etwa 20 bis
30 sekunden auf stufe sechs verrühren
und so sieht es dann bei mir aus wenn er
keine termine und das rezept trotzdem
auf werden wollt könnt ihr das natürlich
auch machen dafür neben dir einfach in
den stabmixer und püriert den spinat gut
durch und dann können dass entweder mit
stabmixer mit den verqueren oder einfach
mit einer hand rück gerät also macht es
einfach so wie ihr wollt ihr braucht
nicht zwingend einen thermomix dafür
dann nehme ich mir mein eiweiß hat diese
eine spinat meister da rein und dann
wird es jetzt einmal sorgfältig unter
gerufen ich mir einfach meine eckige
backform ihr könnt dann ganz normales
bascats benutzen aber ihr wisst ich
nehme mal ganz gerne diesen humana back
rahmen das ist ja wie bei einer
biskuitrolle dann kann ich es später
schön rausholen es ist alles schön eckig
an den ecken und gut sein habe ich
vergessen zu erwähnen dass ihr noch
etwas parmesan braucht ihr müsst es
nicht machen aber ihr könnt ich denke
das passt jetzt auch ganz gut
den habe ich jetzt hier einfach ein
bisschen rein
[Musik]
da einfach dieser spinat tag drauf schön
gleichmäßig und dann vorsichtig
verstanden
[Musik]
kommt es dann bei 200 grad etwa zehn bis
zwölf minuten in den ofen
nach zwölf minuten sieht es bei mir dann
so aus ich möchte es mal den backen
müssen
[Musik]
unternehmen durch einen bug papier legt
um drauf und dann könnt ihr nämlich das
ganze einmal stützen
und wenn's leben sollte gibt es einfach
noch mal einen backofen weiter möchte
nicht ganz
[Musik]
das jetzt einmal abkühlen
die spinat platte die ich jetzt
abgekühlt und jetzt werde ich den
frischkäse noch ein bisschen sitzen aber
ihr könnt theoretisch auch kräuter
verstöße benutzen gibt da ist einfach
mit diesem verein und dann könnte auch
kräuter nehmen mich vielleicht bisschen
basilikum und salz braucht man etwa die
creme schon ein bisschen also frischkäse
bisschen gesagt und dann kommt es hier
auf die platte und ich verstehe das
jetzt einfach mit meiner palette
[Musik]
wie man als erwähnt könnt ihr ja auch
heute steht sie benutzen
ich hatte dir jetzt nicht da habe ich
deswegen auch nicht benutzt
ich fand jetzt die variante mit normalem
frischkäse und etwas pfeffer gut salz
dann würde ich das natürlich auch nicht
weil einfach die salachs so intensiv im
geschmack ist dass wir da einfach da
keinen geschmack man braucht es werden
viel zu dominant deswegen wird doch
eigentlich reichen wenn man nur den
frischkäse drauf streicht ohne pfeffer
aber entscheidet es einfach für euch wie
geschmacksintensiv ihr das haben möchte
und dann kommen da jetzt einfach
erreichen
[Musik]
das jetzt einmal fest aufgerollt und da
könnt ihr euch ruhig das backpapier zur
hilfe nehmen
und das so fest drücken
[Applaus]
und dann will ich das jetzt einmal was
so ein und kann es dann für eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank geben
nach einer halben stunde nämlich dann
die rolle aus dem kühlschrank und legt
sie mit der schnittkante nach unten also
wo und dann schneide ich mir hier
einfach stückchen ab ich würde mal sagen
so 1,5 bis 2 cm dick
und wenn ihr zwischendurch das messer
wieder sauber macht dann habt ihr auch
keine frische spuren außen vor
[Musik]
und dann können dass er auf ihren
tellern anrichten
[Musik]
dann sind wir auch schon fertig wie
bereits gesagt könnt ihr wohl eher gut
vorbereiten einen tag vorher könnte es
einmal den kühlschrank lagern und eben
kurz wasser wären dann aufschneiden
das ist eigentlich auch ein ganz gutes
rezept was man auch mal irgendwo hin
mitnehmen kann weil man eigentlich die
rolle am stück mitnehmen kann und dann
direkt vor ort eben zerschneidet jetzt
wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachkochen hoffe dass euch das rezept
gefallen hat und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder mit einem anderen
rezept und ja bis dann tschüss
[Musik]